hi it's Matthew Martin from details and
we just finished the first show in Paris
which was wraps image this show is all
about a David Bowie's silhouette some of
the pieces that I found really
interesting in this collection where
there were these great Blazers that had
these bars over the top of the chest
never seen that before and I thought
that was a really interesting design
element which you know of course rappers
known for he also did these great felted
coats that were sleeveless and they had
a bunch of zippers on them they were
long and they headed to the long gated
very Bowie asked silhouette there's a
lot of layering in terms of like really
thin turtlenecks over which there were
these great dress shirts that had these
exaggerated elongated collars and cuffs
and I was obsessed with all the printed
sweater vests I thought they were really
fun and it was something I haven't seen
in a while and was definitely a
throwback to the 70s I think overall you
know this is a very wearable collection
like I loved all those pleated elongated
trousers those you can easily put with a
fitted jacket or a pea coat also I think
a lot of the shirts and the turtlenecks
and lasers are really plastic items and
even though they had interesting
different design elements to them it
doesn't mean you can't pair them with
clothes you already have keep checking
it with details calm for more videos
from Paris and you can follow me for
continuous daily updates on Instagram
and Twitter at details math
you